[Applause]
from the moment he took
office it was clear the administration
of donald trump
would be very different from this day
forward
a new vision will govern our land
from this day forward it's going to be
only america first
it didn't take long for the united
states allies to realize that meant they
were now dealing
with the most disruptive president since
world war ii
straining the system of international
order built over
75 years trump moved quickly
to dismantle the achievements of the
obama administration
at odds with all his closest allies he
pulled out of the paris climate deal
believe me this is not what we need and
then the iran nuclear agreement this was
a horrible one-sided deal
later in the midst of the pandemic he
withdrew the u.s from the world health
organization
today terminating our relationship with
the world health organization
not only did he pull the us out of the
u.n human rights council
the hypocritical and self-serving
organization
trump rarely ever stood up for human
rights and at times he seemed more
comfortable
with the us's traditional adversaries
than its closest allies
we now know from some of his advisers he
came close to pulling out of the us's
most important military alliance in nato
summit meetings like this one in
brussels were awkward events with
everyone else
treading on eggshells to avoid the ire
of the impulsive
often ill-informed u.s leader
most u.s allies around the world are now
breathing a sigh of relief
despite the drama after november's
election
president-elect joe biden's foreign
policy is easy to summarize
reverse direction re-sign
agreements and work collaboratively with
allies
america is back ready to lead the world
not retreat from it once again sit at
the head of the table
ready to confront our adversaries and
not
reject our allies ready to stand up for
our values
the relationship the presidents before
trump built with their allies
was based on trust it's a commodity that
takes a long time to grow but is easy to
lose
and that's the problem for the biden
administration the us's closest allies
will be looking over their shoulder
wondering whether in four years time
trump will be back and if it's not him
it could be another president with
trump-like
america first policies james bay's
al-jazeera washington okay let's get
more on that story for you joining us
live on the newshour al jazeera senior
political analyst marwan bashara
good to talk to you again foreign policy
narrative comes down to personal
skills doesn't it interpersonal skills
so does that mean that mr biden's going
to get on with
everyone because he's been around the
block for so long now
well certainly his 48-year experience in
politics
and in foreign affairs does give him
an an extra asset if you will over both
his predecessor and his predecessor's
predecessor
meaning president obama and president
trump he does have the experience
there's no doubt both in washington and
in the world and i think that's going to
serve him really well
to do the things that he said that he
will do
uh he will he will move in confidently
uh he will as it were uh you know hit
the hit the ground
running and that's why as we've heard
from various reports in
his first day in office he will be
signing a whole number of uh
executive orders perhaps 12 of them
including ending the banner muslim
muslim
muslim majority countries to travel the
united states and a whole bunch of
others
that are important for him to restore
that faith in america to restore
america's greatness or
if i may use the expression peter to
make america great again
after its decline under trump marwan you
can say that one time and one time only
we'll let you away with it this time
do you think his focus though will be
led by ideology
or will it be led by issues i mean you
and i are old enough to remember say
jimmy carter jimmy carter liked to
cherry-pick
issues around the world much the
annoyance
of his own political base sometimes he
put human rights at the center
of his international the international
aspect of his administration
will mr biden have to do the same kind
of thing
well that's the thing president carter
for example was that the total outsider
that he was a you know little known
governor of georgia
uh not much known outside the state uh
until he really broke out of
after the disastrous years of of nixon
right
what we have here is something
completely different biden is the
antithesis of
an outsider he is the ultimate insider
and that's why i think it's going to be
less about ideology and more about the
continuity
of american leadership in the world of
american
leadership of the liberal order in the
world which means
mainstream liberal foreign policy
which means restoring as biden calls it
the spirit of america and what is the
spirit of america
well it is civility at least claiming to
respect human rights
not to be such a mean president as uh
president trump was known
to be so in order to restore what biden
likes to call
american leadership in the world he's
going to have to restore
america's alliances around the world
that again
president trump has trampled all over
and in order to do that
he's going to have to have some program
of some sort for the time being what we
know it's going to be the antithesis
of trump meaning yes building alliances
going back to some of the important
agreement including climate change the
iran nuclear deal
and perhaps some new nuclear deals with
the likes of russia and china
re-assert america's leadership over
international institutions that's sort
of a continuity
of mainstream liberal american
policy which i think is is in some way
ideological but it is a continuity of
almost
half a century of that okay if he does
score some
real international successes here when
he gets beyond
the blitzkrieg of executive orders
unpicking the early days of the trump
administration
how much of that will be tinged with or
driven by
nostalgia not nostalgia in the united
states but nostalgia
around the world because there does seem
to be a genuine
need for a more thoughtful a kinder
gentler washington when it comes to how
it
interacts with other heads of government
around the planet
well yes and i think that's a bit of
where the paradox
lies on the one hand america's allies
notably notably in europe
and southeast asia would like a sort of
the return of america the restoration of
american leadership because that does
support them against
their nemesis whether it's china and the
south china sea
or whether it is russia when it comes to
europe but just to be clear
america's policy has not always been
kind and nice and wonderful
just you know our recent memory we
recall the wars in iraq and the wars in
afghanistan and so on and so forth
america has committed
more than its share uh you know of wars
and
and crimes and so on and so forth around
the world which of course president
obama admitted uh as as much
so in so many ways yes it is about
historical
leadership but in so many other ways to
restore credibility
that's going to take time because i
think the europeans for example
have already made their peace with the
fact that they're going to have to go
it alone if need be that
whatever the future relations with
washington it can it cannot go back to
the pre-trump years
only that europe is going to have to be
treated with mutual respect
and mutual interest that germany and
france and europe as a whole
has uh you know super power interest as
it were
and so they're not going to trust just
the words
of biden they're not going to trust
words in general they're going to have
to
look and they will look be looking for
deeds
meaning not just executive orders but
how
biden will rebuild alliances how he
how will he go back and lead and support
financial and otherwise major
international institutions
like the unesco like the international
human rights council
and likely like the climate change
initiatives and so on and so forth
it does look from that for example let's
say climate change
he already put an emissary and not just
anyone
john kerry which which you know if
if if a if foreign policy is decided by
appointments clearly some of his
appointments
do signal a certain seriousness in
tackling some of the
important global challenges facing
america and the world
i suspect we'll talk about this a lot
over the coming few hours a few days as
well marwan many thanks mawan bashara
there
our senior political analyst